yeah welcome to this video 15 minute
game let's see what opening we got yeah
I cannot do much about them the
opponent's strength is pretty low rated
let's see what happens which would g5 is
a bit uncommon here it's probably not
too bad but it's very rarely played okay
let's play h6 first trying to get some
commitment out of this bishop so it goes
to h forum if i play Bishop b4 check now
Knight c3 would lead to the NIMS oh and
i don't think i have a name um yeah good
alternative I can play C 50 d 5 but
let's play the check our this is
interesting now that's there's some
tactics possible with g5g five we should
G 394 and I'm pinning the nite nite g2f
3g for and then the question is if if
I'm winning material but we can probably
play a three and tricky I think this is
even an online yeah there's nothing new
Under the Sun I'm not sure if this is
really good for me no I think I think
this is not good g 594 not a 3g phone
hey I think a three so if this is not
good what should I play without spending
ages of time I could I could play c5 of
course
just just a normal kind of move
especially against 92 yeah come on not
one to invest even more time in this ok
I captured so hmm this is a bit
different now this g5 issue because now
i would have queen a5 also as a
possibility from whom yeah that's still
a three what can you do and okay I just
oh do I have some some alternative yeah
just just captured this come on okay so
it just develops his pieces let's um
let's guess I him what you always can
can do and this kind of structure is set
up a hedgehog and this is probably what
what I'll be doing here so are we
treating the Bishop to e7 friend then g
6 a-6 and so on set up the Hedgehog aha
now sisters this is interesting I cannot
take right I mean they're sometimes
tricks here with Bishop before but I
could play Bishop before it should be
forward what what is he playing then
nothing yeah but now this is this is
interesting now I could take on the form
yeah I will other one a couple of minor
pieces here i also have g5g five Knight
f6 Queen f6 Bishop g3 Queen takes be to
your opinion this will threaten Bishop
texty tomb looks good young g5 but 94 of
course also interesting if I would get
three minor pieces and a big big
development lead yeah the only problem
is if I take on d 2 at the end it Sam
this assault position is a bit tangled
it's not quite sure i'm not quite sure
if i keep all the pieces this is a
problem yeah probably i cannot keep all
the piece of this is the ratio I think
94 bishop DEA drug d8 Bishop d3 maybe
and then I could take but this pieces
won't won't get out I mean I will I
would probably lose 11 minor piece on
and all this in this process I cannot
calculate this and then in a minute or
two and what g5 should be fine right
yeah okay come on this is at least at
least good for me mm-hmm but 94 was
interesting
yeah now he must take on f6 yeah that's
no no other move I think Queen have six
Bishop g3 Queen B 2 and then I'll
threatening Bishop takes D to winning a
piece I'm not so sure what he what you
should do I mean I would win at least a
pawn if he would play let's say Roxy one
man could even think about grabbing a 2
as well so it's at least a pawn okay now
is some investing time guarantee he
needs to check on f6 what answers them
and I takes g5 has some this kind of
stuff is just nonsense just a piece for
me I don't see any other move yeah now
takes f6 is the only move I need to
check afterwards the sinaitic see for
this is always funny do to to sacrifice
the Queen for a couple of minor pieces
so often fun to play this is why I took
a bit of time to check this but I think
at the end I'll I'll lose one minor
piece unless there's some syntactic
which is of course possible especially
considering that after 94 Bishop da
drooped yet verrucous on the default so
and maybe can play quickly d5 and get
even more and on the deform maybe it was
possible yeah now it's taking a really
long thing not quite sure um what are
you thinking about
yeah i played this as i mentioned i'm
probably am doesn't lead to much
especially okay at first first taking
come on so we should wish it takes now
yeah now i have Bishop takes t2 which is
um an immediate problem the idea being a
bishop d2 Queen d2 94 and then walking
you should be 892 and we exchanged lots
of pieces and the Queen's are off even
this is some should be M should be good
really only question is after 92 at the
end of this line what happens if white
moves the bishop there should be seven
for example and then rook e8 but I have
94 at the end and can can retreat yeah
another should be should be fine yeah
the issues after Bishop d 892 his now
add some bishop on datss also it's just
hanging he needs to react immediately
and I also threatened to to exchange on
f1 so the same so give them so solve
this problem offered probably stranded
night you should be seven rook e8 and if
you move the bishop anyway also play
with 94 and secure the night why I can
take everyone named as mentioned yeah
okay I'm now let's check first if
there's some other move not f1 you will
take fhm this makes not much sense of
rook e8
yeah and I'll take one of the bishops
next move with an extra piece for two
pawns yeah ok so I think it's good to
get rid of one bishop ok now can I can
even immediately get pressure on safari
this is good utilizing this pin so who
looks the eight yeah let's just play
rock see it and win this pawn need to be
slightly cautious but then at the end
I'm okay sis a bit too slow here that
that my pieces on PA and aids really get
them still get into the game I can also
just take with the bishop here maybe
this is better yeah the H pawn the kind
of last last hope but i always have king
h 7 ER to stop this so let's secure the
bishop on its nice post page six i just
go to h 7 m ok just develop yeah also
from 95 coming yeah 95 shot should be
what 93 is a big big threat and he
doesn't have any great squares to go to
Jeff please look into md2 I'm i have
rope the aid at least yeah also night
d3n before can be good yeah okay Alice
this is a rather big Fork yeah I can
also just take me to instead of them
exchange yeah this is two pieces now
like resins yeah bit of a bit of a
mismatch I must admit but you're it's
simply this Auto pairing system you get
all kinds of opponents um let's check
quickly this critical position which
sure what's interesting here here I'd
like to quickly check Knight takes e4 I
when g5 a certainty the best it's
probably the best move but I'd like to
check this quickly because I'm just
always fascinated by this stuff Bishop d
aid and now look at the ATM and now I
thought Bishop d3 computer actually
wants to play king e tune with plus one
for white Bishop d3 yeah down no this
was the line that I couldn't really
assess because if you look at this
there's this stuff and hmm it's not
quite clear all of this should be good
for white if i could if i take here then
some of my pieces are a bit entangled d5
yeah i saw d5 and thought maybe this is
working in a way but it's a it's very
difficult to assess let's say f3
you and what's happening now yeah the
computer yeah this is what I meant maybe
their tactics the computer now wants to
play Bishop a 6cm yeah this kind of
stuff but you cannot I cannot calculate
this that's really possible the idea
being that this is quite funny but both
threats iam this is the main line that
the computer is giving with an
assessment of equal funny yeah this is
very interesting for black but I cannot
assess this really and the time and
maybe not even in longer with longer
time more time available but ok and
there was this g5 move which is simply
simply am simply good for me and okay
this this was what I thought would be
normal but certainly why this in huge
trouble what what should he do the only
move is pretty much look see one I think
this kind of Stephanies is even more
more material so Luke c1 and here is the
question if I really should should take
now on d 2 because I well this is the
rather nice spin and maybe there are
alternatives I could take here and then
this is smooth not quite not quite clear
what down what I'm doing now treat and
then maybe this kind of stuff I'm two
pawns up but Queen age five we should be
five hmm it's not clear it's not so
clear
yeah funny the computer after Roxy one
even suggest f5 which is the cool move
intending f4 yeah black is probably out
probably much better here now so let's
not a piece down it's not the same maybe
this both this cleared wanted term I
guess for black yeah thanks for watching